soirée
[Musique]
ça fait plaisir de vous voir tous les
cas alors salman rushdie bonsoir pouvoir
donc vous êtes ici pour votre nouveau
roman qui s'appelle shalimar le clown et
qui est publié chez plon
c'est un livre très réussi qui raconte
la fin du paradis terrestre qui était le
cachemire et qui prend d'autant plus de
relief cette semaine suite au
tremblement de terre dont a été victime
la région mais auparavant je voudrais
faire un point de la situation avec vous
ils ont été condamnés à mort par une
fatwa de l'ayatollah khomeiny en 1989
suite à la publication des versets
sataniques
[Musique]
quand vous avez appris cette fatwa à
l'époque
est-ce que sérieusement vous pensiez que
vous seriez encore en vie en 2005
non je ne pensais pas je me suis dit que
c'était vraiment une menace très
sérieuse et qu'il serait peu probable
pour que je vivrai mais maintenant quel
a été le moment le plus difficile à
cette époque salman le moment le plus
difficile c'est le début parce que là
c'était quelque chose de très difficile
à gérer on ne savait pas quelle était la
réalité de la menace on savait pas ce
qui allait se passer
qu'est ce qu'il fallait faire ce que ce
qu'il ne fallait pas faire c'était une
vieille d'à certitude de traîtres et
bouleversante
alors pendant presque dix ans vous avez
vécu caché en angleterre sous la
protection de scotland yard
mais votre vie ne s'est pas arrêté pour
autant vous ne vous êtes jamais exilé au
bout du monde
vous n'avez pas changé de nom vous avez
continué
à vivre votre vie et vous avez déclaré
changer de vie ça serait pire que la
mort
je ne veux pas de l'avis d'un autre je
veux la mienne et nous avions une super
bonne et des écrivains c'est des gens
très têtu il ya beaucoup d'écrivains qui
ont été persécutés n'y a pas que moi on
les écrivains ont toujours réagi à la
persécution de manière assez
extraordinaire et moi j'étais peut-être
inspirés par ces exemples je ne voulais
pas me laisser faire
alors votre tête est mise à prix jusqu'à
2,8 millions de dollars a demandé moi je
ne s'était pas vraiment de l'argent dans
le tangible
j'aurais pas recommandé de personnes
auraient payé vous voulez bien d'un
texte je pense pas non en tous les cas
votre adducteurs italien et japonais ont
été attaqués votre traducteur japonais a
été poignardée votre éditeur norvégien a
été blessé par balle dont c'était
quelque chose de très sérieux et malgré
tout ça vous avez déclaré en 2001 dans
le new york times comment vaincre le
terrorisme
ne soyez pas terrorisé même si vous avez
peur
c'est que c'est exactement la façon de
niort a réagi après l'annoncé par t -k
une période pendant laquelle les gens
avaient peur c'est vrai et puis très
rapidement
en l'espace de six mois les gens ont
simplement 40 arrêter d'avoir peur du
lit où continuent de vivre et je crois
que c'est la seule réaction possible
parce que soit on s'enferme dans un coin
en tremblant swallows et donc je
continue à vivre et je crois que toute
la ville de new york times est même
réaction la même avec son que moi la
fatwa a été levée en 1998 c'était à
l'occasion de la coupe du monde de
football c'était en raison des coûts
devront effectivement on se moque de la
coupe de football
alors aujourd'hui vous dit mener une vie
normale d'un romancier ordinaire vous
vivez à new york avec votre nouvelle
femme la quatrième vous changez plus
d'appartements tous les mois vous
promenez plus avec des gardes du corps
vous allez dans les vernissages et dans
les premières vous c'est sorti de votre
tête
oui vraiment c'est une vraie des
histoires il termine et puis comme je
dis septembre à titre d'exemple avec mon
épouse nous sommes ensemble depuis six
ans et demi et elle ne connais rien je
sais pas c'est pourtant à la fatwa n'est
pas levée elle n'a pas été annulé quand
même mais en réalité pas le vrai danger
voyez vous c'était le désir du
gouvernement iranien de mener 2 2 a bien
d'exécuter la fatwa ce qui n'est plus le
cas et donc que le vrai danger a été
dissipé ces et d'histoire c'est du passé
même le nouveau président iranien laqué
quai paquet pas un tendre
en tout cas c'est l'information que j'ai
reçue alors il ya toujours des
manifestations chaque année le 14
février à téhéran
la presse est hystérique pendant un jour
ou deux mais ça passe quoi
disons que c'est surtout une question
rhétorique il n'y a pas d'application
pratique alors que par le passé c'était
tout à fait concret aujourd'hui ce n'est
qu'une il se dévoue un mot je peux pas
vous le prouvez pas mais croyez-moi
c'est vrai alors là la presse iranienne
dit chaque année comment ce suppôt de
satan
peut-il encore vivre non seulement vous
vie
mais vous écrivez vous publiez donc un
nouveau roman qui s'appelle shalimar le
clown chez plon alors au delà de
l'intrigué c'est un petit peu le roman
du cachemire alors vos grands parents
étaient kashmiri c'est nanan jeudi et
tous les ans vous alliez en vacances au
cachemire dit je me souviens pas d'avoir
vu un endroit plus beau avec les neiges
éternelles et puis et puis une grande
harmonie c'est à dire que les hindous
était un petit peu islamisés les
musulmans étaient un petit peu un do is
et et il n'y avait pas vraiment d'esprit
militaire on se moquait des kashmiri
parce que finalement c'était des gens
qui avaient pas se battre et qui était
plutôt pacifique et et harmonieux
exactement et c'est l'une des idées
triste ironie de cette histoire c'est à
dire que l'endroit le plus paisible de
toute l'inde
là où les gens étaient connus pour
justement cette vie d'harmonie ces gens
qui ne s'intéressait pas à la guerre ces
gens se trouve cet endroit plutôt est
devenu le plus violent de toute l'inde
est une tragédie sans nom parce que
effectivement les gens en plaisanter en
eo disait des cages vérifier qu'ils
étaient il n'avait pas le moindre esprit
d'humilité ça devait être des lâches
en fait c'était pas d'éloges c'était des
gens qui aiment et qu'il y ait la paix
oui alors les difficultés ont commencé
avec l'indépendance de l'inde après la
deuxième guerre mondiale
l'inde a été divisé en trois c'est à
dire qu'ils avaient au centre l'inde
hindouiste et puis d'un côté le pakistan
occidental de l'autre côté le pakistan
oriental qui est devenu le bangladesh
par la suite
et là il ya un maharaja patron du
cachemire qui hésite entre l'inde et le
pakistan et c'est là qu'ont commencé les
problèmes évoqués posture review dans
les faits ça c'est connais pas ce que
c'était un maharaja hindoue même si la
plus grande partie de la population
était musulmane elle a paniqué savais
pas quoi faire et il a choisi la voie
des maharaja c'est là qu'il s'est enfui
alors l'armée indienne sur ces
entrefaites est venu en théorie pour
protéger le cas ce n'est le cachemire
mais depuis cette date là il ya eu cette
guerre avec le pakistan
ça c'est le fond je dirais politique ou
géopolitique et puis à une intrigue
shalimar le clown raconte l'histoire
d'un jeune mu
le monde kashmiri ils ne sont et bon qui
épouse une superbe danseuse inde où
c'est un peu roméo et juliette quoi
avant que celle ci n'accepte de le
trahir
pour suivre un riche ambassadeur
américain qui lui promet le monde alors
c'est c'est à cause de ça que shalimar
le bong shalima rejoint le jihad
vous êtes toujours une erreur de partir
avec un ambassadeur américain
on ne recommence quelle que soit l'issue
surtout parce qu'en l'occurrence si vous
êtes une jeune danseuse 4 kashmiri
l'ambassadeur américain ne vous verra
pas comme de ma partenaire avis ou une
partenaire
donc on aurait pu prévoir la catastrophe
c'était à nous c'est effectivement c'est
ce qui ce projet et shalimar le koung
qu'il aimait réellement le coeur brisé
mais ça va au delà de ça ce n'est qu'il
a perdu sa femme qui a été prise par un
homme et de puissance de pouvoir et donc
c'est sa virilité en quelque sorte qui
est mise en question et donc il est
cesse de se reconstruire en tant
qu'homme et c'est ce qui l'amène à
choisir la voie de la violence alors le
livre commence par un meurtre c'est le
meurtre de cet ambassadeur américain par
salima qui est devenu son chauffeur et
ensuite vous fonctionnez par par
flashbacks et on découvre toute
l'histoire alors c'est ce qui est
intéressant avec ce bouquin c'est que
c'est un roman qui traverse l'histoire
mais qui aussi couvre tout le globe
c'est à dire qu'il ya des récits de vie
de gens dans des endroits très éloignées
en inde en europe aux usa et est
aujourd'hui sur la terre c'est vrai on
est tous dans la même histoire notre
histoire et mondialisé et je crois que
c'est un des premiers romans que je vois
comme ça qui peut parler à tous les gens
de tous les pays mais c'est exactement
notre vie aujourd'hui qui n'est pas
cloisonné dans des petites boîtes
soutien des boîtes sont ouvertes sur les
autres photos que c'est en fait un peu
mon premier roman pas français puisque
max l'ambassador est d'origine française
il
il est né à strasbourg qui est une
région un peu comme le cachemire
l'alsace qui a été partagé entre
l'allemagne et la france que j'ai appris
beaucoup de choses sur la ville de
strasbourg
j'ai appris beaucoup de choses sur
l'occupation nazie sur la résistance et
mouvements de résistance et c'était
passionnant alors voilà en parlant
d'histoire vous avez un point commun
avec michel houellebecq que nous avons
reçus dans cette émission il ya quelques
semaines c'est que vous pensez que la
vague intégristes va refluer vous dites
dans dix ans dans 20 ans l'intégrisme
musulman qui est tellement fort
aujourd'hui tellement violent
aujourd'hui va se calmer
pourquoi votre avis je pense que c'était
un phénomène connaît tous vous vous êtes
comme madame soleil vous connaissez tous
je ne suis pas prophète
j'ai déjà eu pas mal de difficultés avec
les pros fait que le jeu ne surtout pas
prétendant être un manège
mais si vous regardez les pays où
l'intégrisme musulman a eu le plus de
deux fois ce sont les pays où justement
où l'islam est le moins aimé le lait les
afghans détestait les talibans les
iraniens aujourd'hui même pas beaucoup
le gouvernement des ateliers en algérie
pendant la période du fait c'était du
gia ses pouvoirs et et était détesté
donc en théorie mais j'ai l'impression
c'est comme une espèce de fièvre le
fanatisme intègre il ya eu des
fanatiques dans toutes les guerres il ya
eu des fanatiques
est ce que j'arrive pas à comprendre
c'est qu'à chaque fois que vous sortez
un livre c'est sur le le fanatique
musulman musulmans musulmans musulmans
musulmans pouvaient pas changer de sujet
de sané - voilà c'est ça ils s'allient
pour montrer comment un musulman doux et
gentil devient un fanatique qui fait pas
un livre sur les musulmans sont
fanatiques mais je viens d'une famille
musulmane
j'ai autant le droit de parler de
l'islam que n'importe qui alors pourquoi
vous n'avez pas répondu à la question
pourquoi l'islam intégriste va refluer
dans les années qui viennent d'après
vous à mon sens je crois qu'il y aura un
recul parce que dans les pays où l'islam
à et gagner le plus de pouvoir c'est
l'endroit où justement le pas
le lem le mois les cachemires il déteste
l'islam intégriste de même que les
afghans de même que les iraniens donc ce
que je dis c'est que c'est un phénomène
à court terme d'accor voilà shalimar le
clown salman rushdie c'est chez plon
est-ce que vous êtes prêts pour une
interview d'accord salman rushdie quels
défauts aimeriez vous avoir la cupidité
quelle est la qualité que vous regrettez
d'avoir l'un gentillesse
qu'est-ce qui vous donnerait envie
d'être trompé par une femme au caractère
qu'est ce que l'avenir nous le dira pas
sur vos peut-être mon sens de l'humour
on ne sera jamais en quoi aimeriez-vous
être beaucoup plus mauvais a rencontré
un gars la colère qui ne voudriez vous
pas avoir comme fan moi
quels sont les défauts qu'une femme doit
avoir pour vous séduire
la tolérance quelle est l'insulté qui
vous a fait le plus plaisir c'est la
portée par l'ayatollah comédie
quel est le compliment qui vous énerve
le plus n'aimait pas le livre le
décrivez bien ce pays quel est le talent
que vous n'aimeriez pas avoir le talent
de d'intimider les jeux quelle est la
question qu il ne faut pas que je vous
pose je ne l'imposé pas qu'est ce que
vous aimeriez que quelqu'un vous volent
en progrès my past peut-être mon passé
quelle est la meilleure mauvaises
critiques qu'on vous ait fait manson mon
fils une femme a dit lors quand j'écris
un livre pour enfants qu'ils étaient
trop lents et que les gens pourrait
s'ennuyer
alors je leur ai écrit un rythme plus
rapide merci salman rushdie jeanny marc
le fur
c'est publié chez dorment là messieurs
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous mettez un
peu de bleu